Hey, this is Clark, and I want to remind you that this podcast is brought to you by ScoutmasterCGcom
Backers. The funds we get from our backers cover the expenses of producing and publishing
everything at ScoutmasterCGcom, including what you're about to listen to. Go to ScoutmasterCGcom
and click the support link at the top of the page and you can join hundreds of your fellow
Scouters who help me keep the podcast freely available for Scouters all over the world.
And now for you, Scoutmaster.
Hey, here's a scouting fun fact. okay, If you took all the Scouts in, all the troops across the country
and you formed a line, that line would stretch from the Atlantic Ocean up to right about where
the dunes are on the beach, where a tenderfoot scout would run out of the line and start chasing
seagulls. About 20 feet from there there'd be a scout whose mom called him on his cell phone to
ask him where he was and what he was doing and when he would be coming home, and by that time
the rest of the Scouts in the line would be getting a little antsy. so about a half a mile
in there would be a game of pickup football going on and the line would be a little wavy from
that point until you got to the place where the senior patrol leader forgot to phone his
patrol leaders and have them show up for the giant scout line that is stretching across the country,
And then there'd be a pretty good gap there and Scouts in Kansas would be wondering where
everybody was and where the line crosses the Rockies. the Scouts in Colorado would probably
be snowboarding and not paying much attention to the whole thing, And on some beach in
California Scouts would be milling around for a while until they decided: you know,
forget this line thing, let's go swimming. You know, you get the idea right.
Hey, this is podcast number 162..
Hey, welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast. This is Clark Green. Well, let's take a look
in the mailbag. Ron Lasala wrote in and he said: I'm a great fan of your site and then he told
me how to fix my karak bend- not infographic- that I published last week. I don't know if
you guys caught that or not. I managed to catch it pretty quick. I fixed it and I had one of the
crossings wrong and oh my goodness. But this is. this is the problem when you proofread your own
stuff, folks. Actually I'm happy that I have a lot of proofreaders out there And you know,
if you find a problem and you see something that I've gotten wrong, get in touch. I really,
I really really do appreciate it. And Ron's in in Tallinn, Connecticut, with Troop too. Thanks,
Ron, Thanks for getting in touch and thanks for helping me out there. Terry Dutton is with Troop
16 in Oak Park, Illinois, And he writes in to say: Hi, Clark, your work is appreciated. I listen
and read, looking for ways to be a better scouter for my Scouts, and your podcasts and blog always hit
home. Thanks for the great work. Well, thank you very much for being in touch, Terry, And
I certainly appreciate the kind words. Heidi Medina Cordero wrote in to say Thanks,
I'm loving it. Thanks, Heidi, I love it when people write in. I really do. David Thompson
writes in from Mililani, Hawaii, Troop 164, and says: I just started my role as Scoutmaster in
January. You have a fantastic resource that has infinitely sped up my education as a Scoutmaster.
Yes, they showed me the volcano and I jumped in. Thank you, And you know, in Hawaii, David,
that's kind of almost literal, isn't it? You can get in touch with me. I send a question,
send a comment or just say hi, And you can do that by emailing me at Clark C L A R K E
at ScoutmasterCGcom. So in this podcast we're going to answer some email questions
And that's going to take care of the rest of the podcast. So let's get started, shall we?
Hi, I'm Kevin Callan and I'm listening to Scoutmaster iPod. No, I can't.
I am Kevin Callan, the happy camper, and you're listening to the Scoutmaster podcast.
I had this question come in. I came across a situation that happened to one of my venturing crew
members who was also registered with a Scout troop. He completed all his requirements for
the rank of life, asked for a border review and his trip denied him the opportunity to have
a border review because he owed them money for rechartering. While I respect that you have to
enforce collection of a past due fee, is restricting an advancement opportunity a valid
method? My view as a unit could maybe restrict youth members participation in camping or other
events due to an outstanding debt, But I see in the guide to advancement that no unit can add
additional requirements to advancement. Isn't requiring a Scout to be paid in full adding
a requirement for advancement? Am I right in reading this into the definition of the situation?
Well, yes, you are. A border review is one of the four steps in our system of advancement
And qualifying. to go before a border review means that a Scout has completed the requirements
and he's had, you know, his Scoutmaster conference, which is one of the requirements,
and he's headed for the board. I can understand theoretically why a troop would have this kind
of restriction. Okay, you know, when you think about it, all right, it makes sense. But
there's some things that aren't being thought about here. These things trump any concerns you
have about financial administration and things like that. I think it's wrongheaded to try and hold
Scouts responsible for the actions of their parents. If a parent has missed the rechartering date,
you know there could be a variety of reasons, especially in today's economic climate.
But here we've got a Scout who's been responsible enough to complete the requirements for the
rank of life. He's asked for the border review and then the board has the sand to say, well,
no, we're not. we're not going to let you have a border review because you owe us money.
When I hear about things like this, I wonder if people have been trained and I wonder if they
get it. The Scouting program is a program for boys. Boys have families. Some families function at a
very high level. They pay all the dues, they pay rechartering fees on time, they pay camp fees
in time. Some families are just a mess And it's not the boys responsibility to try and
fix his family. If you have a policy or a practice in your troop or your pack or your crew that's
making life hard for a Scout who may be at the mercy of a dysfunctional family,
reconsider what you're doing, would you please. And I think in the case that was stated in
this email, I think that you're off base procedure wise, because you are adding,
you're adding another requirement that is preventing this, this Scout, from getting a border review.
Let's get trained, Let's get on board and let's figure out exactly what we're supposed to be doing.
I also received this email. I'm a fairly new Scout master and I asked our committee if we could
just go ahead and give merit badges and rank patches out at troop meetings and then hold the
certificates and present those at the court of honor. They declined to do this because they said
if they handed out the badges at troop meetings, no one would ever show up for a court of
honor. Then I noticed that they were handing out an Eagle Award to a Scout who wasn't even on a 100%
uniform? How do I change things when a committee seems to be stuck in their old ways? How do I
ensure parents and Scouts are going to attend quarterly courts of honor, even if their Scout
didn't necessarily advance in that last quarter? What you write about is a good example of a troop
practice running up against recommended best practices. A recommended best practice is
something in the literature or training that's not necessarily a mandated procedure, and I think
it's pretty well explained this way in the Guide to Advancement. Under a paragraph titled
Mandated Procedures and Recommended Practices- and you'll find this on page two of the Guide to
Advancement. The paragraph reads: this publication clearly identifies mandated procedures with
words such as must and shall. Where such language is used, no council, committee,
district unit or individual has the authority to deviate from the procedures covered. Recommended
best practices are offered using words like should, while other options and guidelines are indicated
with terms such as may or can't. So you've understood the best practice about presenting badges
at troop meetings and then presenting certificates at courts of honor. Here's where it's
mentioned in the Guide to Advancement, and this is section 4.2.1.4.. The Scout is recognized.
It reads this way: When the Board of Review has approved his advancement. the Scout deserves
recognition as soon as possible. This should be done at a ceremony at the next unit meeting.
The certificate for his new rank may be presented later during a formal court of honor.
So notice in that paragraph the word should and may. It's not shall or must. okay, What's
being recommended here is a best practice. It's not saying that this is the only way to make
things happen, but it's a best practice. Now the committee is worried that if they don't
hold on to badges, Scouts won't attend the next court of honor, and I can see that's an
understandable concern. but I think that that concern is misdirected. I'd be more concerned that
there's one or more things in the way you guys are presenting a court of honor that may be causing
the problem. So let me ask you these questions: Who's running the court of honor? To my way of
thinking, the senior patrol leader ought to be the master of ceremonies, aided by his fellow
youth leaders. If it's the Scout master or the troop committee handing out badges and
taking a long time to do it, or maybe just a short time to do it and the Scouts are just watching,
it's not likely they're going to be very interested in attending. Why would you? Okay,
I've got my badge and all's I'm going to do is sit there and listen to the Scout master or
the troop committee spout off for a while and they're going to bring me up and yeah, I don't
need to do that. How long is the court of honor? Now? I would tell you that our troop
courts of honor, you know, with a troop of about 35 Scouts, average maybe a half hour to 45 minutes.
If we're presenting an Eagle rank, which we do as a part of our regular troop courts of honor,
it may go as much as an hour, an hour 15, but we keep that time brief and meaningful rather than
long and kind of hard to deal with. What's the program at the court of honor? Is it
appropriately formal without being, like, incredibly overblown? I think simple words, spoken in honesty,
are always better than a lot of pageantry. Scouts want some formality and ceremony, but they don't
want it to the point where they're reluctant to participate. Remember yourself when you were that
age Now, some of us would have thought that standing up in front of a bunch of people in
our Scout uniform and saluting and getting our hands shaken and badges presented and everything
like that was pretty cool and we would really enjoy doing that. Some Scouts are not going to like
doing that very much and they'll you kind of have to encourage and congel them. So it's just a
minute or two and it's important that you stand up here as an example to your fellow Scouts and
the families that are here to be recognized for your achievement. If we're putting Scouts through
this kind of gauntlet of ceremonial things that they have to do and everything, consider that
they might not want to do that and think about what the program is like and think about maybe
rewriting it and starting over again. What else is happening at the court of honor? I'll say that
our practice is usually to combine our court of honor with some announcements and discussions with
parents. It's kind of like a parent's business meeting for a few minutes before each court of
honor while the Scouts are getting ready to talk about our schedule of camping trips and
rechartering or friends of scouting or whatever information needs to be exchanged. and it also
gives parents a chance to bring up questions and things, but only for a few minutes. It's not
an hour long thing, You know. it's relatively informal and this is value added for a parent
and it's an encouragement for them to attend. When is the court of honor? We hold our courts of honor
in place of a regular troop meeting on that troop meeting night, so that way it's on everybody's
schedule already. You got to think about a family with a couple of active children. They're likely
to have a pretty involved schedule of meetings and activities, and I think it's important to
make things as easy for them to remember and to attend this kind of thing as possible,
because they already have a pretty busy schedule. Now, if you apply some of those ideas- like when
the court of honor is, what's happening at the court of honor, what the program is, how long
the court of honor is and who's actually running the court of honor, you may find that parents
and Scouts are a little more interested in them and make a point to attend. Now, that being
said, there's little chance you're going to get every single Scout and family to any given court
of honor. so do what I do: Concentrate on who shows up and remain aware that a few simple changes
may make it possible for a lot more people to get there. It's not the fault of families and
Scouts when they don't attend something like this. We ought to look at what we're doing,
how we're doing it and why we're doing it before we get too upset that nobody's showing up for
what we're doing. Scouts and families vote with their feet. if they aren't showing up,
it's more than likely that we may have something off base. Now you also touch on something that
a lot of Scoutmasters ask: how do you get a committee to change their old ways?
and the answer all begins with training and studying resources like the troop committee
guidebook and the guide to advancement and the Scoutmaster handbook. I mean, we all too often
think that we have to wait for a training event. You know, we look at a council or a district schedule.
we see a training event as a couple months away and we think, okay, we're going to go do that and
we try and encourage the people working with the troop to get there. and you know what happens.
The schedules are this way and that way. training events can fall at bad times and all of a
sudden, instead of five or six people getting there, it's you and maybe one other person. Don't
limit yourself that way. take the initiative and get your adult volunteers the resources
and work with them to learn about these things together. There's a number of resources out there.
there's online training through scoutingorg, there's training events, like I said, at your
district or council, and there's always asking somebody to come and hold a training session
for your troop and your adult volunteers. If that is unworkable, how about studying
things together as a group and using what resources you can find online? Think creatively,
get everyone trained or retrained and make that an annual thing. Once you start thinking about
these things, old habits have a tendency to get changed, especially when you see the wisdom
in a lot of these recommended best practices. I would make one observation about the ego
presentation you mentioned. Uniforms are a best, recommended practice and they're not required
by policy at any time or any place, and you'll find this in the guide to awards and insignia, on page five,
which says- and I'm quoting: while wearing the uniform is not mandatory, it is highly encouraged.
the leaders of scouting, both volunteer and professional, promote the wearing of the
correct complete uniform on all suitable occasions. Whenever I mention this, I get a lot
of comments, and so let's be clear on something: Yes, uniforming. yes, uniforming is one of the
methods of scouting. yes, uniforming is important. yes, uniforming is highly encouraged. We've made
the mistake sometimes of thinking that it's mandatory and then enshrining unit rules about
uniforms and things like that. What I want to do is just encourage you to think about it. okay,
and this email came across the transom this week. I'm writing to share part of an email from a
parent about merit badges, because to me it's a classic helicopter situation. Here's what she
wrote: can you tell me what badges my son has partially completed at summer camp? I'd like to
work with you to get these finished up now, between now and summer camp, and I would like him to be able
to register for merit badge work at camp on new badges instead of spending his time finishing
badges from last year. Additionally, I'd like to talk to you about his earning some of the eagle
required badges, like the citizenship badges and things that seem pretty intense. I would like
to plan his summer around badge work versus signing him up for all kinds of busy work camps around town.
My challenge is is that this parent hasn't picked up on the general hints about the
onus being on the scout, the importance of his own interest and motivations being driving
factors in earning badges, the real learning that comes from communicating these things.
So I'd love to hear your thoughts on how I can send a clear yet respectful message to this
parent when the subtle hints I've dropped don't seem to be enough. This is actually a pretty common
thing. Parents can be kind of hard driving. they get behind their boys and they really drive them
on advancement, and I think that we can do what we can do to explain to them that this should
be boy driven, that this should be based on a scout's interests and he should be allowed
the latitude to administer his own advancement in the way that he sees fit. Not every parent is
going to get this and this is not going to be consistent with every parenting style out there.
So what do you do when there's a hard driving parent? Well, first of all, we don't punish the boy,
right? We're not going to make remarks about his parents or the way things are going or
anything like that. We're going to cooperate with this parent. We're going to do our best
to help satisfy what they're trying to do. We don't really know what's going on at home, do we?
We don't know what this parent's driving at. It may be that, hey, we just have one of those
good tiger moms who's driving the kids pretty hard to achieve, or we may have a mom who's a bit
worried about her boy and trying to help him focus and trying to help him use his time wisely.
Absent that knowledge, what I would encourage anyone facing this kind of situation to do
is to accept the fact that not every parenting style is going to be absolutely consistent with the
way that you see parenting and the way that you see scouting, That parents are supporting
their boy's participation in scouts because they see that participation as being something consistent
with the goals that they have for their sons. If they're going to drive pretty hard and
they're going to have maybe more to do with what then we think is appropriate with
shaping what their sons do in scouts, we're going to deal with it as diplomatically and as kindly and
as respectfully as possible. We're not going to make the scouts suffer for the actions of their
parents and we're going to cooperate as much as we possibly can with what parents are doing.
Don't take that advice as the thin end of the wedge where we just say, oh well, we can't help
anything, so we just go and we do whatever parents want us to do. You know, sometimes
there's a line and we need to point that out and we need to say: look, you know,
for this to work the way that you want it to work and to achieve the goals that you want it to achieve,
I'm going to recommend that you think about maybe stepping back a little bit and helping him focus-
yes, but making sure that he's focusing on the things that he wants to do rather than the
things that you want him to do. Sometimes a little kind nudging and advice like that works,
sometimes it doesn't, and getting ourselves too exercised over it can have negative results for the
boy and negative results for the family. so you know, that's my best advice on the situation.
everybody's going to handle a little bit differently, but at the basis of it, we're cooperating with
parents for what they want for their sons. So if you have a question, you can email me
and you'll find out how to do that in just a moment.
well, thank you so much for listening. now here's how to keep in touch. you can read the scout master
blog at scoutmastercgcom, where you can subscribe to receive updates to the blog by email. you can
subscribe to the scout master podcast on iTunes and when you do, please leave a comment to review
or a rating. you can access the podcast on your mobile device through stitcher smart radio
and you can get details about how to do that at stitchercom. you can also experience the
wonders of scoutmastercgcom through the vast panorama of social media outlets. that's right.
you can follow us at scoutmaster blog on facebook, tweet scoutmastercg on twitter and, for exclusive
admittance to the exclusive scoutmastercg circles, search for scoutmastercg on google plus. if all
else fails, there's always email. yep, that's right. zoom into the 90s with me and email me your
comments and question and wild ideas at clarkclarke at scoutmastercgcom.
clarkclarke at scoutmastercgcom. the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast are not official
publications the Boy Scouts of America, nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
no, it's just me sitting in my little home office with a microphone and a laptop,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders and maybe have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun, here's our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell. Sir Robert,
good luck to you and good camping, why? thank you, sir, until next time.